a bunch of the guys were sitting around
and talking about
what would happen if ronnie died would
any of them like try to [ __ ] stephanie
you know your girl young girlfriend good
question you want to know the answer
don't you oh i want to know the answer
well okay this is fantastic ronnie
you're gonna love this
because now you're gonna know we called
some of the guys
and we said we'll be stephanie you be uh
you
and stephanie comes on to you we wanted
to see what they would do it's silly but
we wanted to see
and most of the guys were a hundred
percent like
right on the money hey ronnie's my buddy
stephanie i'm not gonna [ __ ] you
forget it there was only one person who
got
right into [ __ ] stephanie oh it's
unbelievable
now if you were to guess i'm not going
to say the answer i'm going to do a slow
reveal
but i'm curious robin you first
who on this staff would like just right
away be [ __ ] stephanie if ronnie
dropped oh i'm going to say
sal okay who do you say ron
i say the same you say sal
yeah you're gonna be shocked
so so here let me hear some people who
wouldn't [ __ ] stephanie who who
did the right thing all right here's
richard they're at the funeral
stephanie's coming on to richard okay
just just listen
richard thank you so much for coming i
think it would have been meant a lot to
ronnie and it meant a lot to me
uh-huh thank you so much you're welcome
you have to leave now yep gotta go take
care of the kids bye
please stay i just don't want to be
alone right now okay
bye you have to leave i'm a dad gotta go
are you leaving yes or no just tell me
i don't hear anybody because i already
left i'm in my car you bastard
i i was down the road after asking the
second time
[Music]
appropriate richard's like but not very
nice
i mean he's not a nice care that
stephanie's is in pain
but here here's gary gary thank you so
much for coming
really meant a lot to me i'm so sorry i
loved ronnie and i know he loved you do
you have to leave now
everyone's gone do you can you sit down
with me i of course i'm not gonna stay
because first of all hey i'm married
and i love my wife but more importantly
i'm not gonna [ __ ] my
good friend's widow who's asking for sex
i just need
an old friend you're a good friend i
just want to sit down and
talk to you um no i could sit and talk
i have a hug just a little warm sure i'm
very sorry for what you're going through
can you kiss me i cannot do that i know
that this is uh
all very upsetting for you and confusing
i'm sure you're you know you're not
thinking straight and
i'm so wet please gary yeah i'm not i
don't i don't want to hear it please
please i have to go you're a bastard i
don't
[Music]
gary's she's wet for chrysler up around
right ryan that makes you feel good
doesn't it yeah
all right guys now i'm going to play you
jd
do you think he was appropriate or was
he the traitor to ronnie
jd hmm i think that jd is going to crack
what do you think ron that's that's
confusing i don't know
all right here we go there's jd and ryan
her ass that's what i'm afraid of
i know do you have to leave now
yes yes i must leave please sit down
just have a drink with me
please sure i have a drink you smell
good huh could you kiss me on the neck
just once get out of here please stop it
this this will not make you feel any
better
uh it will i am not any i am not
uh this is this is just not right
so can i have a kiss on the cheek i give
you a kiss on the cheek but if you turn
it gets me on the lips i'm outta here
don't want to spend the night i'm going
to be all alone please stay
no jd just spend the night i beg of you
listen
uh i'll if you need me to spend the
night i'll spend the night but i'm not
going you go to your bed and i'm staying
on the couch
okay good night good night okay so now
you're sleeping jd can i suck your [ __ ]
no can you rub my shoulder no
after all this no that's a bad idea if
you had maybe if you had
maybe said i need a shoulder robe
originally
okay now i just need a shoulder up bye
i'll rub your shoulders oh you give a
great massage
you mind if i i'm gonna play with myself
yeah goodbye goodbye thank you
hands off hands off i'm out the door
ah jd he's you're broke dude he slept in
the [ __ ] house though
it was a woman in emotional distress
she was scared to be alone perhaps who
knows exactly
yeah i'll give you a massage though
whatever yeah whatever i didn't do
anything i'm your bro i love you but
there was one
who went right in for it you guys think
it's out i'm gonna tell you this
what it wasn't sal okay who's
left sal was honorable
[Music]
will murray a little snake in the grass
will murray he
[ __ ] that um
it was benji who was the traitor
i didn't even like a [ __ ]
it's unbelievable i'm going to play you
the clip now watch how quickly it turns
sexual
you have to leave now oh i know i i can
i mean i
i'm i'm happy to talk and i have a hug
please i just wanna of course can you
kiss me i don't think that's
the best thing for you right now it is
it is i'm just
i need he's just one kiss
oh my god
[Music]
um can i put your hands on my pants yeah
oh you're really wet stephanie feels
good
yeah it's just so wet
and so hot i put my hands down your
pants i love that
feels good oh that does feel
good you want me to put my [ __ ] all the
way inside you stephanie yeah
and you're sure ronnie would be okay
with this yeah he would
but
[Applause]
[Music]
wow yeah oh my god your pussy's so tight
oh ronnie wasn't even called in the
ground how could he even say
you think this will be all right with
ronnie hump hump hump
i could see it being a little bit
weirded out but i also think
the horniness would overwhelm that and i
think
an honest answer but yeah wow
but but a rotten answer
oh wait i'm told that someone else [ __ ]
stephanie in this scenario too
oh really so you weren't the only one
there was one other person who do you
think it is ronnie
i i don't know it's someone who doesn't
get on the air a lot but he has been on
the air with us
i'll tell you who it is let me you're
not going to get it yep mike perlman
i'll play the tape that's the same guy
who
stole my bagel and said he didn't
i come back bagels all unwrapped the
paper towels are gone
and i think i know who did it go ahead
there's only one person there
so and he loves to [ __ ] with me because
he thinks everything is a big joke
so who was it perlman perlman michaelman
he wants everything you've got yeah
let's hear how bad it is
you have to leave right now or could you
stay i
i just don't want to be alone right now
oh yeah i can hang out with you for a
little bit if you want me to
you look good thank you so do you how's
work
oh it's it's hard and you know i'm can i
have a hug
sure come here oh my god come here you
smell so good
thank you your muscles are really strong
thank you stephanie it's in my lap i'd
love to
probably exhausted from uh all the
planning for
the shiva and funeral and everything can
you rub my shoulders
i'm sure absolutely your arms are
incredible
your hands feel so good can you kiss my
neck mike
can you do that absolutely can you put
your
hands down my pants please sure oh
you're about to flood this place why
don't you get on the table get on the
table
i will see that cocky ears mike sure let
me take it out right now
so hard hey can you just suck my dick a
little bit first
[Laughter]
i kind of suck your [ __ ] inside of me
yeah let me leave you down first
i feel so good let me let you down
good acting i do think ronnie had all
the staff because i think if someone had
to do it
i think he'd want me to do it i don't
know who's wrong
do it if someone if you had to pick
somebody i think he'd pick me
i would think benji's a good choice
because you know it'll be a disaster
i'll miss you nah she could she couldn't
deal with all of benji schtick man
no way what's up rob hey now i don't
really get how
it's wrong if ronnie is dead for
somebody
to get with stephanie what's the problem
ronnie's dead it's not a betrayal
and stop it well that's kind of what my
thought process was it was like okay
if ronnie it's a hard thing to put
yourself in that position but if ronnie
had to put himself
in that position who would he pick i
don't know wait can i just say something
howard it wasn't just that we're
hooking up with stephanie we're hooking
up at the funeral you know what i mean
like we're literally like ronnie's not
even in the ground yet we're hooking up
yeah like we're consoling her and then
all of a sudden we start fogging her
yeah it's very funny i've ever given it
to the thought i said to myself i would
never do ronnie dirty like that that's
horrible
i heard the tape dude you you
practically came on the casket the way
you were carrying on